so my top career tip for women in tech
is to surround yourself with incredible
role models
i think one of the best things that i've
found for myself and my career at google
and my career broadly
has been learning from and surrounding
myself with incredibly smart talented
motivated people
and these are people who lift me up who
champion me
and who give me the opportunity to
champion and lift up others
know how to overcome imposter syndrome i
face it
every day but i have learned to really
focus on
the value that i bring maybe you're
scared that you're not technical enough
or you don't fit this
idea of what someone in tech should be
but that changes every single day and
we're redefining it as women bring your
whole self
don't worry about what in tech is
supposed to mean
i used to be a photographer used to
shoot a lot of concerts
in a pit with a lot of men and what i
learned
by navigating that scenario i feel like
it's very applicable to my day-to-day
life
now a career tip that i feel like has
been told to me and that i've tried to
pass along to others
is this idea of following your curiosity
so rather than mapping out like a
perfect
uh you know five-year plan or pursuing a
particular title
uh more so kind of paying attention to
that little voice inside your head that
says
like something is really interesting and
kind of pursuing
projects that feed that curiosity when
you work in tech you are so lucky for
many reasons
but one is that so many fields and
verticals can benefit from tech
so advantage number one is that you can
work in so many different fields and on
so many different
problems and of course advantage number
two is that if you work in tech because
you have this unique perspective that's
so valuable
you have you're very hirable right you
can work in a lot of different places
i have a tip on how to overcome the i'm
not enough fear when applying to your
dream job
the solution is building a skills-based
resume
rather than a timeline empathy has
taught me that people need to really
quickly understand if they should call a
candidate up or not within the first 30
seconds of reviewing a resume
so really save your detailed experiences
for interviews and
only share a few relevant items that
make employers curious to learn more
about you
my one tip for women in tech just don't
be afraid of trying different
technologies and
roles you might surprise yourself with
what you find and what you like
get comfortable talking about your work
so many of
us have this mental hurdle of am i
bragging
is it too much should i be talking about
myself shouldn't my work be talking
about myself
but the reality is we are great
cheerleaders of others
we talk at length about their
accomplishments but and we need to be
equally good at talking about our own
work
to value your own perspective and remind
yourself often
it's super easy to get into that
comparison trap but a difference
is not a weakness if you're not happy
with the current way of working or
with the culture of our society and you
want to be the one to initiate the
change
my strategy is to set your mindset to be
curious
and optimistic and stay persistent with
what you believe
embrace changes as they come and be
prepared for any opportunities that may
come by
so that you're always ready to take on
new opportunities
do not fear be brave woman belonging
tech do not let anyone make it otherwise